the president still says though that the
report is a total exoneration but the
experts say not so fast because the
actual report paints a very different
picture on the issue of obstruction of
justice Muller does not draw a
conclusion on that though the Attorney
General did clear the president of
criminal wrongdoing the report says this
while this report does not conclude that
the president committed a crime it also
does not exonerate him the president
told a White House event yesterday that
he's been vindicated I'm having a good
day too it was called no collusion no
obstruction there never was by the way
and there never will be
the president faces no criminal charges
but the Muller report opens the door for
Congress to take action the Muller
report says quote Congress can
permissibly criminalize certain
obstructive conduct by the president
because those prohibitions raise no
separation of powers questions with us
now as Democratic congressman Jerry
Nadler of New York he is chairman of the
House Judiciary Committee Chairman
Natalja good morning welcome thing
morning heared morning as you read this
report
do you see obstruction of justice I see
considerable evidence of obstruction of
justice which is what Muller said Muller
said there was considerable evidence of
obstruction of justice the report
concluded there was substantial evidence
that President Trump attempted to
prevent an investigation into his own
camp into his campaign in his own
conduct sites eleven instances he
doesn't pursuit he doesn't make the
charge essentially because Justice
Department guidelines he believes
prevented him from doing so but he lays
it out for Congress and he practically
invites Congress to pursue that to
pursue that so yes I should intend to
have you issued have you issued a
subpoena to get the full report we will
in about an hour yes issue the subpoena
this morning's bar bar seems to have
acted over the last four weeks including
yesterday not as the Attorney General of
the United States but as the president's
personal attorney he would do most
yesterday well he lied about what was in
the report he misrepresented it waiting
everybody well for instance he said four
times no collusion
the report specifically says that
collusion is not a legal term we it
showed any number of instances which use
shows mentioned of of cooperation
between the campaigns and the Russians
that's what's commonly conceived as
collusion but they couldn't charge
criminal conspiracy they didn't have
enough evidence to charge criminal
conspiracy not collusion and one of the
reasons it says they didn't have enough
evidence to charge criminal conspiracy
was that people in the campaign various
people destroyed evidence lied committed
perjury lied on an obstruction of
justice the the they didn't they didn't
clear the president they specifically
said that an FBI if we had confidence
after a thorough investigation of the
facts that he did not commit obstruction
of justice which states we would say so
based on the facts and however we and we
are unable to reach that judgment and
they invited Congress specifically to
pursue that bar took it upon himself to
announce that he decided to clear the to
clear the president it's not up to him
but the Republicans now say listen the
reporters out it's time to move on why
do you feel it's not time to move on
because the report is very damning it
paints a picture of a president who lies
all the time
licensed staff members then the demands
that his staff members lie who tried to
obstruct justice was prevented from
doing so in several cases by the by the
refusal of his own staff members to
violate the law even though he told them
to it paints a picture of a campaign
that was in bed with there was
completely in bed with the Russians
weather why didn't mother come to a
different conclusion if what if what
you're laying out is true that's what
I'm saying is exactly the inclusions he
came to he said he couldn't find enough
evidence to to prove beyond a reasonable
doubt criminal conspiracy partly because
people lied and refused and refused to
testify the president the bar says that
the president one of the evidence that
why the president didn't obstruct
investigation is because he cooperated
totally he didn't cooperate totally he
refused to testify he refused to answer
questions about
destruction of justice at all and most
of the questions about the Russians he
didn't remember the bottom line is we
have to hear from bar that is the
Judiciary Committee has to hear from bar
which we will do on May 2nd and from
Muller as much as Muller answered your
subpoena when that we haven't issued in
the subpoena we're inviting him I mean
probably answer the invitation that will
probably extend the invitation today or
tomorrow we are issuing we need the
whole report we need the whole report
including the underlying documents
unredacted as has been the case in every
previous situation similar to this with
Congress guided well the American people
need the whole report - some redactions
which Congress should decide on and we
will subpoena that report today where
are we headed with all this the
political remedy is impeachment is that
where we're headed let's I don't know
where we're headed we are headed to find
out a lot more to hold proper hearings
to educate ourselves and the American
people and we'll and we'll see where the
evidence leads you make a very strong
claim about the Attorney General saying
he's basically behaving like the
president's lawyer and not the Attorney
General that seems like grounds but
that's grounds that seems like grounds
for some kind of action from you as well
I mean you're basically saying he's
doing the opposite of his job yeah but
it's not up to it yes I think he's not
doing his job properly or I yeah I think
it seems he's not doing his job exactly
as the president's personal attorney it
certainly seems that way but we will
invite him we have invited him to
testify and let him justify his actions
before the committee in Mason you're one
of the congressmen who will get the
opportunity to read the less redacted
version of the report when do you intend
no no no we've been no I did I've been
invited to read the less redacted
version of the report on condition that
we take no notes and tell nobody about
what we read what's the point of that
Congress is a collective body and if I
read something and I can't tell the
other committee members about it or the
other members of Congress it's useless
that's frankly it's insulting to
Congress that offer is insulting to
Congress we will work to have an
accommodation
with with the Attorney General but in
terms of seeing the rest of the report
and the underlying documents but it
cannot be under such restrictions that
we cannot function and that's why we
need the subpoena your colleague Adam
Schiff says about impeachment you don't
bring a case if you don't think you're
going to be successful just to try the
case do you believe with that general
principle not necessarily as a general
rule that that's certainly prudent
action but I can imagine a situation in
which to vindicate the rule of law and
protect the Constitution you have to
bring a case even if it's not gonna
ultimately be successful but there are a
lot to take the country through yes yes
but I can I'm not advocating that god
I'm certainly not advocating that but I
can imagine a situation in which that
may be the necessity to vindicate the
rule of law and to protect our
democratic process all right now but
it's a general I've laid out a
three-part test for impeachment yeah and
you do the last word and I'm gonna say
this look two of them are are two of
them are really from from I think
established in the record you don't
impeach a you don't impeach somebody you
don't bring an impeachment procedure
unless one you think you can prove that
the president's committed impeachable
offenses - they're serious and featural
offenses not just you know and three and
this is a more Prudential thing I don't
think you should bring a an impeachment
proceeding unless you believe at the
beginning of that proceeding when you're
starting that you have such strong
evidence of such terrible deeds that
once that is laid out to the American
people an appreciable fraction of the
people who supported the president will
agree reluctantly you had to do that
because otherwise you get a situation
where the country is divided to the next
30 years the computer is gonna cut you
off so I'm gonna go because we don't
want any won the election Thank You
chairman Adler for coming we appreciate
it it's 8:12 we got a go time to check
your breath local weather